ich hoffe es einfach aus am 10.10.10
voraussicht also auf jeden fall jeden
fall vorbei und nicht selbst dazu auf
punkt aus dem fenster sehen so der
stetig und ist dann wer steht auf jeden
fall fest schadet man das ist mir
einfach nicht gesagt hat aber nie was
geht ab nun tue ich hoffe ihr habt einen
wundervollen tag bisher gehabt
ich bin gerade aufgestanden fühle mich
dementsprechend scheiße wir fragen wie
was bei ihm so abgeht du hast doch schon
vor langem geplant also ich weiß jetzt
nicht wie das da gebe ich dir recht man
kann wirklich liegen
ich wollte gerade endlich sagen dass man
neben dafür dann kommst du auf jeden
fall erstmal hier wieder schönes mädchen
reiten wieso setzt du dich jetzt dahin
waren auf jeden fall vorne ist noch ein
bisschen weiter kennen ich putze die
zähne putzen waschen auf die coolen
könnte deutschland lage zu machen
hier könnt ihr euch noch an den bauch
von vor zwei tage ändern oder das wetter
einfach so geil war dass ich mit einer
pizza luftmatratze im pool a
typisch deutschland schauen wir heute
aus dem fenster bei regen fuhr ich
verstehe das nicht deutschland ich war
immer mehr mensch und ich find dich ich
habe es eigentlich vielleicht gar nicht
immerhin brach vielleicht weil ich wie
ein braver mensch ich habe auf jeden
fall gleich einen termin bei einer
hantel die mir im gesicht pickel
ausdrücke und ich habe gehört dass ich
mal herzlich auch das also wird auf
jeden fall dran wäre gerade damit dass
sich an seinen sollte wegen seiner
hässlichkeit hey wurde
ich mache mir jetzt erstmal schauen um
ein joghurt noch da ist gehört komplett
übernehmen und jetzt erstmal alles ist
schön kaputt machen hier ja von meinem
blog in kurzen instagram pushen laser
luca okay
gerade zu diesem termin da also ich hab
eigentlich nicht die pickel im gesicht
aber ich wollte etwas schlimmer aber
waren weil alle meiden so war das mal da
war danach fühlt man sich wieder
ausgeführt stück wunder also dass gleich
wieder ich weiß nicht viel anders geht
vielleicht reißt mir nun vielleicht 35
minuten keine ahnung
das ganze hat jetzt irgendwie anderthalb
stunden gedauert war verstärkt als
lustig ich gesagt das mache wie pickel
ausdrücken gehört seit kurzem wieder als
würfel gemacht werden oder ich mache
jetzt habe ich so eine gesichtsmassage
bekommen ich schlafe geht auf jeden fall
treffe ich mich jetzt mit meiner mama
nirgend sonst am markt weil ich mir so
ein paar sekunden einkaufen sollte sehr
gute kameraperspektive übrigens
flughafen
ich will dass sie sich so aus wie diese
pflanzen von harry potter manchmal gibt
es aber mal so was du dich gefunden
guck mal max kostet 49 90 wir waren
jetzt halt wirklich nicht im laden der
irgendwie schnäppchen hier so sollen die
zahl einfach super schnäppchen
trotzdem habe ich irgendwie 80 euro
ausgegeben ich gehe jetzt erstmal noch
eben einkaufen ich hab dem eingekauft
ich wieder zu hause angekommen was
machen wir da natürlich erstmal
[Applaus]
bis man essen aufgegessen und auch ein
video hochgeladen und youtube hat er
jetzt sein eigentlicher zeit ein neues
design habe ich am letzten loch schon
was du gesagt und dabei nicht eigentlich
okay ich fand's eigentlich gar nicht so
stritten die neue design änderungen aber
jetzt wollte ich klicke hier auf videos
das funktioniert jetzt gerade noch
richtiger play dass das funktioniert
überhaupt nicht jetzt auf einmal kommen
wenn ich hoffs kolle nach oben ist auf
einmal mein banner jetzt ist hier alles
dann wirklich auf play das steht hier
was ist das youtube dass ich wirklich
nicht an mein browser oder an der
internetverbindung hier weil twitter und
facebook in dieser allen seiten gehen
ein perfekt aber youtube
diese bringt den designer raus ist
funktioniert ich fahre jetzt auf jeden
fall zu einem kumpel der kollegen zu dem
ich jetzt ein paar hat sich beim letzten
zu kriegen job einfach wie fucking
schaufel gekauft so frage ich nicht
warum ich die ganze zeit bieten
entwertet ist jetzt definitiv am
schalter er wir sagen der gewinner
christlich zu prims schaufel ja 2 1
gewonnen
luca war ja zu lesen
amazon stellt gleich abschließen
chinesen wissen aber ich kann auch gehen
ich habe jetzt die kernprodukte klotz
erste was man für das volk mit fenster
gramm
ich hasse laser luca luka das nicht
zensieren machen wollte ich höre luca
hallo in dem ich mal weg um im jetzt und
hier macht man geht ja fünf wirklich
gute leute lukas so schlecht nicht hier
ist unglaublich
sie ist gestorben was mit dem ok es
nicht mehr hier aber der tod und das mit
mir alter jetzt will ich auch zu hause
macht spaß mit so ich bin jetzt weg von
mir hat haben wir aber zu einfach nur
getroffen und haben so etwas gefressen
bisschen gezockt und ich will jetzt mal
ab aber falls du das sehen sollte bin
ich nicht in der person ja ich bin der
sohn
und wie war es wieder zu hause
angekommen freunde ich bin ich so hart
caro aus alter ich bin auf jeden fall
auch hardcover die letzten nächte nie
viel geschlafen wegen früher aufstehen
harz eminent dies das wäre
[Musik]
obendrein ist es laut es ist gerade
einfach helfen 750 ich habe irgendwie
das gerade geschlafen und es hat so gut
getan mal wieder zu zehn stunden zu
können aktualisiere gerade die ganze
zeit die seite und hoffe dass der shop
jetzt jeden moment aufmacht
oh mein gott freund ich hab so zeger das
maus-team bekommen es ist dieser orangen
das wetter so sieht der etwa aus dass
ich mit dem palace logo und das ist
wahrscheinlich so ein frottee stoff
genau aus dem gleichen material habe ich
auch schon da habe ich jetzt natürlich
nicht dabei aus dem gleichen material
ist offen ist ob das nun mal geholt habe
und dass kuba steht also wo ich freue
mich freundlich kurzes update freuen das
ist gerade 12 4
als meine bestellung habe ich von einer
minute abgeschlossen jetzt mal
heute mag ein junge zum frühstück
sondern ein paar brötchen auf den punkt
irgendwie wird das nicht so besonderen
mama kann man diese lieber wusste noch
essen die es seit sechs wochen
abgelaufen
[Musik]
das war doch ein fortschritt bei red
room for green bei dem piano lied das
bringe ich mir gerade bei aber jetzt bei
der damen und herren kommt etwas noch
viele sehr lange gewartet da man sich
sehr viele der fünf stark und zwar super
reagiert ich habe auch kein intro dafür
also wir fanden direkt mit dem ersten
video also ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz
genau wieso mir das eingeschickt haben
weil ich glaube das macht eigentlich
jeder immer so wenn er in einem
elektronik fachhandel q1 autohersteller
würde ich sagen ich habe mir das video
mal direkt mal das stimmt definitiv
was irgendwo auf der welt unterwegs und
lassen eine laden gesehen namens pizza
luca oder lokal ist das das gleiche auf
jeden fall müsste die partie italien
waren jeder zweiten ecke also ich weiß
nicht ob mir das aufgefallen ist aber
als ich zum beispiel damals in venedig
war diese wirklich gefühl jeder zweite
pizzeria an ein paar luca ich weiß nicht
warum meine damen und herren
dazu nehme ich jetzt sogar mein team
konnte kamera weg und bewege mich ein
bisschen das hat eigentlich gar nichts
mit der message jetzt zu tun ich habe es
halt aufs netz steht einiges gesagt ich
habe in einigen blogs teilweise
unterhaltungen von telefonkonferenzen
reingepackt oder wenn ich will ja
unterhalten habe und ich habe viele
kommentare gekommen von wegen
worum geht es denn da was ist denn am 10
also dieses datum habe ich ja teilweise
war so ein bisschen erwähnt es hat etwas
zu tun mit pizza und ich würde sagen
meine damen und herren ich hoffe es
einfach auserzählt im zehnten
voraussicht also auf jeden fall
irgendwann oktober
eine eigene pizza das ist ein fettes dem
ich saß ein letztes mit studio zusammen
und bedachten und so hey luca auf was
auszubaggern ich dachte ich wollte
unbedingt mal eine pizza warten wir auf
alle gelassen da dachten wir ja schon
nass wenn wir das wirklich machen würden
daher sehen wir jetzt in verschiedenen
herstellern hingegen damals gesagt hey
wir haben hier luca and legal waffen ein
gewitter zu waffen haben und dann sind
wir zusammengekommen mit gustavo musste
das ist ein pizza hersteller aus
süddeutschland nehmen beispielsweise nur
regionale zutaten für ihre pizzen nur
ausgewählte sachen wenn ich aus dem
umland die pizza von er ist auch größer
als gibt es dann von anderen herstellern
und ich finde persönlich gesagt schmeckt
auch besser als die von anderen
hersteller selbst dahin gestellt um mir
das jetzt glaubst oder nicht und bleibt
ein aber was soll ich habe schon mehrere
gegessen ist einfach nice ich habe auf
jeden fall so ein paar ideen gehabt
würde luca pizza also von wegen
irgendwie okay wir nehmen die margarita
und den käse auf der pizza ist
beispielsweise ein smiley oder irgendwie
so war es aber ich halte die idee der
salami auszubringen auf den salaten die
scheibchen auch hier runden scheiben ist
dann der smiley drauf oder irgendwie
sowas sagte ist dass wir so was halt
komplette maschinen hergestellt werden
müssen und welche maschinen die sowas
herstellen können schon mal so in den
siebenstelligen bereich kosten und das
ist sehr teuer deswegen werden wir als
pizza jetzt erstmal margarita
herausbringen wird für oktober am 10 10
voraussichtlich die wir in verschiedenen
rede ich noch alle möglichen
informationen demnächst zu sagen auf dem
karton wird das mal die sache in der
karton ist komplett von mir die wahrheit
also so clean wie es irgendwie geht
in den kartons werden einzelne sticker
drin seien zehn verschiedene sticker
davon gibt es noch relativ häufig und
einer ist sehr selten dass dick habe man
den hat kann man sogar etwas gewinnen
der muss auf jeden fall so ein paar
sachen überlegt aber ich möchte nicht
alles jetzt schon verraten so dann werde
das auch ab und zu auf der iss seinen
twitter oder napster raus und ich halte
über laser lokal so folgt jetzt erstmal
weiter bedenklich aus ptfe wtf an der
stelle muss ich hier bin ich mal sagen
dieses mädel kriecht ein ratschlag hin
mit einem verdeckten smiley gesicht ich
kriege nicht mein ratschlag hin wenn ich
die augen komplett auf habe und der
stellt natürlich als allerdings auf die
heutige episode von luca reagiert
beenden
ich fahre jetzt zu meiner oma meine oma
war und wo noch was zu essen
omi romy die ich als meine ich war jetzt
gerade zwei stunden bei oma und opa und
wir haben uns einfach über alles
mögliche unterhalten man sollte wirklich
öfter zu den großeltern gehen finde ich
also ich mach ich bin jetzt selber kein
gutes beispiel so ich bin halt die
hauptsächliche zeit meines lebens in
köln oder unterwegs oder keine ahnung
was aber es ist wirklich so schön
irgendwie finde ich wenn man bei oma und
opa ist als man das jetzt auch schon ein
bisschen vergesslich das einzige was die
wenig an zeit gesagt hat ist luca das
was du jetzt machst du für dich
entscheidest willst du dein leben lang
machen das hat sie mir so circa zehn mal
mitgeteilt aber ich finde das irgendwie
so süße die versuchen eine so die
eigenen erfahrungen tipps mitzugeben aus
dem eigenen leben ich mal meine oma und
opa sind jetzt auch schon über 85 finde
dass also ich weiß nicht nur zuhören
großeltern
keiner ist übrigens fragt jetzt mein
abendessen aussieht mit fettes brot
deutschland
deutschland führt deutschland sage mal
so ich bin schon der größte so kannst du
deine fresse halten wenn ich rede ich
bin jetzt gerade im schnitt vom heutigen
video fast fertig geworden lange dauert
nur noch hat caro ist gerade irgendwie
halb drei morgen werde ich auf eine
kirmes fahren
deswegen muss ich fit sein ich werde das
hier an der stelle jetzt allerdings auch
beenden wenn euch der block gefallen da
würde ich mich sehr über einen like von
euch freuen weil es ihr noch kein
abonnent von einem kanal sein sollte was
natürlich sehr beschissen wäre könnt ihr
einfach unter dem video auch abonieren
klicken und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
bekommt ihr nämlich benachrichtigungen
auf euer handy sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen sonst würde ich jetzt
sagen sehen wir uns übermorgen in einem
neuen blog wieder und macht so gut haut
rein und da
[Musik]